I feel like you don't spend money
a little Scrooge you are you know you
are and I think people wonder if I'm
rich or not I looked it up you're Jesus
but I I know that's usually off I mean
you're I think they usually do that with
shoveling everything in a pile not doing
taxes or that you live that agents and
managers and stuff like that that is or
that you've paid for anything in here I
love celebrity Network like pull up
celebritynetworth.com I love guessing
people's not as good one you can do a
high like let me throw you one um Daisy
Fuentes oh fuck
who can be the hardest one first Daisy
Fuentes remember Daisy Fuentes she was a
host yes MTV very nice girl Daisy
Fuentes in the ideas days I guess wait
does she have a clothing line
correct he does god damn he does she's
got like a Kmart I just it's exercise
okay fourteen I'm gonna say 14 million
18 go this is fucked I'm scared I'm
gonna what wait where is it 300 million
what get fuck not achieving 75 million
go down here the second one what top
went from MTV 300 million up what does
she Jessica Simpson what if I just took
yes
what were the assholes I'm gonna go work
for her I love we're low balling easy
Fuentes damn I thought I was going high
75 million
she's got exercise club where her
collection no I'm not going to the
Golden Globes launched a clothing line
hey girl I'll do sponsored content for
daisy fuentes spandex sports bras you
know what your lines be called hey girl
hey girl hey guys hey guys guys guys
guys all right let's do another one ah I
have a serious subject by the way oh no
what is next one give me somebody good
I'm Ryan Seacrest okay I ever gonna be
hi he produces the credit okay give me
an own sindbad sindbad is good jokes
again give me my underwear so old it's
just a rubber band
okay Sinbad I did a gig with and by the
way just well while the Google is you
know computing yeah thanks in a while uh
I did a corporate and he was opening for
me and in a strange series and I go oh
no you're going first
and I know he's good I go oh no this is
gonna suck and he goes yeah and he went
out and I go what kind of companies is
anything that's true you know it's like
Orkin or something yeah and I go oh yeah
I go I'm gonna go I'm gonna leave your
can yeah don't bug me then I'll just go
talk so funny I go right under my accent
but they'd like you to incorporate the
company you know I don't you know it's
they're like hey Jim's our VP he's got
three balls and beats his wife working
it and then you say it one guy laughs
sit back and what else fuck mom dying in
Hanson yeah say something know these
things it's funny yeah and then he so
Sinbad goes up and rush --is for a solid
half hour and everyone's like oh he's
like this over Tim over there ain't no
afterlife he's using the microwave he
did he like studied the company and he
gets off but I'm like god dammit I was
out there like fuck someone else I
thought he was the main guy and then I'm
like eh everybody like I'm all cool and
they're like but you know they just they
weren't bad but they were not good and
they just sort of struggled through me
and I was like I just walked out there
delirious going fucking Sinbad killed
killed that also happened once I was
doing this event at the David Lynch
foundation it's a it was a chair it's a
charity for meditation something and I'm
cold
no I'm cool wedding look you in your
bomber jacket wait is it new 12 grand
it's what did you ask me no it fits good
look is that new because I told a
producer on your show that you should be
wearing bomber jet oh yeah the show we
had a very long conversation about it
yes you told Tom and Brad are you told
no I told Adam one of your producers
animating it yes because on your show I
was fucking looking and you're always in
like a ski jacket
you're always like Amal I am in a and
you're like a North Face ski jacket yeah
like a norm corner cool Silicon Valley
billionaire on vacation and a rapper in
a video okay so that one's house sounds
mean if I go low why no okay
but he had a sitcom well nine final
answer okay what's yours I have 15 700
million what if he invented something
eight million Oh four million this is
not fun by the way four million is a lot
damn no this is we should keep doing
super high ones because we look like
assholes formula if you had four million
you jump off a bridge if I had your
money I'd throw mine away pretty single
I have a couple I have a couple more I
wanna know and the people you guys
better be guessing this listening Stacy
Keibler she still have the treehouse for
the elves dum-dum
Oh Oh goddamn stay close all right
okay you're always joking video stacey
koon it was oh okay well what was she on
she was on Dancing she's a wrestler than
just dancing stars an actress I don't
know anything about wrestling money I
I think she's married to a very rich guy
cuz I know they bought a house that's
right that post Clooney so what do I say
to that after the after a woman breaks
up a Clooney she gets married within six
months within seconds I know it's the
only way out because you can't yeah okay
what's your guess I'm gonna say I did
she have a line she have a tanning line
or a hair extension lesson rings bet she
doesn't even know who this is you know
she is no Benton is young and knows
youtubers I know he's like you're on the
David dub hey CK so okay no Daisy case
does not word that much
okay Steve are you are you quietly
writing
now I know you wrote just shoot me is
that how I just wrote it I was gonna ask
about I think that's exactly the font on
the script it's true actually you know
what I mean I just look I just wrote
shoot me down and it looks like the font
from the from the show go ya know a lot
of people on Instagram have questions
about stuff okay well I'll get there
right after list basically but I'm gonna
say cuz she's tied in him now forty
million twenty one four point five this
must be before they got married yes and
boy sorry for those of you love how we
four point five million for Stacey keep
C's done well for herself well there's
another 125 million for her what the
fuck are wrong I think
celebritynetworth.com that's the one I
go to that's the one that I what about
the guy Richard Simmons what do you get
horrible why 26 million thirty ten tapes
he videos yeah what do you think is a
lot of fucking money photo 32 million
Richard Simmons the Mike final answer 15
million fuck he got robbed he's been
robbed I know how about this give me one
of your youtuber I feel like you get a
bad deal I don't know why you think I
know about all the YouTube you do teryn
right now are we at tick time dude
Trisha Paytas said that he's obsessed
okay Trisha Paytas Trisha Paytas
probably has more money than all of us
combined Trisha Paytas what is she she's
a YouTube star
she eats on camera and she had breaks
down it does she have a brand no does
she have a views of her ears use for
YouTube so ads and applying and and how
much okay so but she's got lots of hits
on her YouTube she also up treaties
model-type on top of everything else yes
yes yes yes yes
Trisha Paytas so Trisha Paytas net worth
I'm gonna gas girl watches are five
million oh yeah she loves you it is that
I think that's true I think I've got the
yeah yeah oh okay
so star being nice I'm gonna guess four
three five six six YouTube ad money a
million more money than Stacey keeps I
know you
and now that one switched it to four oh
I like this Oh everyone's rich
everyone's rebels get branch five but
what if it said like 20 great well I
mean Logan Paul is Pratt's location
jeffree star do jeffree star net worth
is that one what is it insane cuz he's
got makeup lines he's got the young no
he owns Rouge companies he may really
cruise for the internet stars great is
my Wi-Fi not working how come let's take
a toll don't even know I'm gonna say
Jeffrey seven five Jeffrey Stehr has
what fifty million YouTube 17:5
Instagram in YouTube he's like he's also
like a famous famous now I haven't made
one fucking penny from Instagram really
you know do weren't we supposed to do a
Briard they are doing it now we're doing
a branded content you are together
you're not doing that I I are doing it
as we are you and I yeah it just came up
again are you
do you say none of that stuff I've
always said no no I'm not I'm gonna do
with you though
oh that we're gonna do it together it
makes to patch together yeah over the
new Sonny and Cher yeah I'll do with you
talk about after but do you woody why do
you say no to certain things I think the
average person average person I just
mean that is like people that watch us
like do you guys think it's corny oh
right we when we should ask your people
Aya's because I've never done one so I
don't need I just think people think I
would be full of shit if I did I don't
they always go you need money I go I
mean when do you stop greatly I mean
Whitney's I'm not my net worth I gotta
make sure your net worth is very high
Google that before you came on I don't
okay Jeffrey started net worth I'm gonna
say 22 milli
okay Benton insane 31 one no shut the
fuck up 50 he's got like MAC Cosmetics
has own cosmetic line yeah up up 40
million I am in the hundreds and add
money from YouTube and and every this
hotels merchant you've got a hotel
yawns all kinds of real estate he talked
very openly about it okay
all kind of what real estate Benton is
from this real estate he's very fancy
okay I'm gonna say 45 I'm gonna say 55
3c all right no a game show 200 milli
you knew that are you didn't know he
knew that Benton knew him and I went a
net worth Benton was trying to help us
guys you're fucking I didn't believe Ben
I liked someone I've never heard of his
wit that's how out of it I am that
thought you're exaggerating you should
have I mean I don't know it does every
show ever go on TV shows no we should do
a secretary try to become famous makeup
tutorial he just does it
did makeup tutorials on YouTube I'm
gonna do makeup tutorials on makeup
people that do it that's a good idea
toriel put Rouge on them here's the
Rouge base